адвокат роман масел до 1 вірша уніч на 30
виступу до побувши беркут
роман шлюб доля в авто пробілах нам
вже кирять табу у сувоєм на законних
ріжте goodyear
з садових ви руки в цих курчат в 300
неправосудних ви руки
тисячі з варшаві кованих рапорті кожен
дзвенить і доль рушники кутів край ваш
кутимо нині ситуація може змінити їх
суть 9 їх паяння було по данина там дев'ять
місяців дай поєднається ось такі ось
дзвенів р-ну сюди ну за новим законом про
стати я буду тут ось так само ще
рада правосуддя топ то процес буде
пак
апарати він і все означаючи ще частку судді
вт і порву вирішив це і самі судді
вона депутата ч президент лекція була
раніше для лариси вільник studies
полтави циpка зад іванівна
ви нас стало ведене після цього я
відкрито заявила протест на себе збоку
мара місця судячи з нас пряма
яншина виведення конкурсний вербер я
кайма я про це його нато inci служителі
феміди а так вже перевірку нотаріальних
залишки таких корпус хибну хотілося б
ти там на
вбитих людям стало
адже місту сьогодні повністю змінити
звідси система
замісти 4 ревниві місць sevis суди
запилювати та не вище спеціалізовані
Верховний Суд України
ти пар будуть три рівні міс метою crush
не опали тіней товар кований суд з
зради робити достроково терміном
залишкового розряду довідка ж експерт
праворуч максима жорен а ось же
економії години та ін жадібні хороший у team
і тут не все так просто нікому на
ведомом механізм чи ким чен нам будуть
тут і доброти суддю позначена не так
рівні закону не акт вищої
кваліфікаційної комісії суддів річки ОМО
б цикл ви означає і порядок провідницею
конкурс на моє его та на травня на віджет на
інформації про публічний доступ акція будуть
зі проходить
подібний ринок і пов'язання з вищим
антикорупційним судом як і травня ніби
створа ну заразом з новим
законодавством там розряду там із
праворуч топ корупціонерів експорту на
глушити хіх успіх судової реформи і
чи треба закласти the mute вид контролю
ламати кістки